alors qu'hugo merci en tout cas d'être
là alors toi maintenant tu es devenu 100
% gt rien pour qui ce qui s'est passé en
fait dit mme bah c'est une accumulation
de chiffres en fait que j'ai découvert
que je connaissais pas parce que pendant
26 ans j'ai mangé de la viande et du
poisson en grosse quantité moi j'adorais
ça j'adore toujours ça d'ailleurs mon
père et chasseurs sous-marins fin tout
le monde autour de moi mange de la
viande et du poisson et en fait j'ai
découvert des chiffres qui montrent nous
en donner deux trois mois on peut pas on
peut en donner quelques uns on peut
donner 80% de la déforestation en
amazonie
c'est l'élevage c'est l'avion on pense
souvent que c'est les mines le pétrole
non on coupe des arbres pour faire des
pâturages et des plantations qui vont
servir à nourrir le bétail
c'est 95% des cochons qui vivent
enfermées dans des bâtiments en france
qui se voit jamais l'extérieur qui
savent même pas ce que c'est de la boue
de la paille c'est 14,5 pour cent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde sont liés à l'élevage c'est
plus que le secteur des transports donc
pour être concret la viande pollue plus
que toutes les voitures tous les avions
tous les trains tous les bateaux du
monde réunis et puis des chiffres comme
ça il y en a des centaines qui sont
incroyables quoi moi par exemple 3
millions promis on sait ce que c'est
honnêtement 3 millions d'animaux
[Applaudissements]
3 millions c'est quoi par million c'est
le nombre d'années c'est le mec qui va
casser l'ambiance 3 millions c'est le
nombre d'habitants d'animaux abattus par
jour en france par 20 millions en france
juste rance ans 3 millions d'animaux par
jour si on veut parler des poulets par
exemple dans france par an c'est un
milliard et dans le monde ces 55
milliards de poulets par an c'est entre
1000 et 2500 milliards de poisson par
2500 milliards de poisson par an voilà
et en fait c'est donc tu t'es dit je
peux plus je me suis dit là mais je me
suis dit j'ai posé la fourchette et je
me suis dit réfléchissons et si on de
voir vraiment ce que ça impliquait ce
qui se cache derrière donc je suis allé
dans des élevages intensifs
j'ai parlé avec des gens qui ont bossé
dans des abattoirs j'ai parlé que des
scientifiques qui m'ont expliqué aussi
que ce que je savais pas alors peut-être
que j'étais un moins cultivés que la
moyenne sur cette question là mais je
savais pas qu'un cochon était plus
intelligent qu'un chien savais pas ça
paraît évident j'avais fait avec un
cochon vous baleineau dans la rue vous
voyez un chien vous le prenez vous le
découper en morceaux vous le faites
cuire au barbecue
non seulement vous passer pour un dingue
mais en plus il ya des lois qui vont
vous condamner parce que ces cochons
c'est pas rien faire ça avec un cochon
en terme de souffrance en termes de
d'intelligence de cet animal c'est
exactement la même chose sauf que c'est
légal et c'est des centaines de milliers
toutes les semaines qui vivent dans des
conditions absolument abominable et qui
sont abattus dans des conditions
absolument abominable
on dit souvent moi c'est ce que je
pensais aussi quand je manger de la
viande les animaux ils souffrent pas
dans les abattoirs parce qu'ils sont
étourdis se rendent pas compte
tous les gens qui travaillent dans les
abattoirs vous dire encore totalement
faux il ya une partie des animaux qui
sont mal étourdi donc ils sont égorgés
avec un plutôt parce que c'est comme ça
que ça se passe encore aujourd'hui de
manière totalement consciente qui
souffrent pendant plusieurs dizaines de
secondes
ils ont le stress ils savent qu'ils vont
mourir et puis toute leur vie si on peut
appeler ça une vie ils sont entassés par
centaines par milliers dans des espaces
tout petit par exemple la majorité des
poulets qu'on mange aujourd'hui ils
vivent sur un espace qui est inférieur à
une feuille a4
quant à lee on a été à l'école ils ont
ça mais je le monde pour que les gens se
rencontrent
voilà c'est ça c'est l'espace par poulet
dans les élevages intensifs toute leur
vie peuvent même pas étendre leurs ailes
ils peuvent rien faire donc c'est pas
seulement la mort qui pose problème
c'est les conditions de vie et puis
c'est par exemple le dauphin j'étais
super choqué quand je voyais des images
à la télé des japonais qui massacrent
les dauphins à l'armé blanche vous avez
peut-être vu ces images
des dauphins qui sont enfermés dans des
parcs aquatiques ont fait des pétitions
s'indigne etc
quelle est la première cause de
mortalité des dauphins et des baleines
dans le monde j'ai fait la pêche la
pêche et de très loin 300000 dauphin et
c'est à ses parents sont morts dans les
filets de pêche
la première cause de mortalité des
tortues marines c'est les filets de
pêche donc la pêche a rien à envier à
l'élevage
voilà j'ai [ __ ] l'ambassadeur pas du
tout j'ai arrêté de manger les animaux